Gilbert le batteur 12 ans
[Musique]
nationale 7 route des vacances
et pourtant la famille Brial ne part pas
en vacances
[Musique]
elle va camper certes mais pas comme
tout le monde
parmi les siens
les gitans
escale d'un jour sur la route ici
corbeille en Gâtinais près de Montargis
les gitans sont installés le long des
grilles d'un parc bien soigné
le parc de la mairie une étonnante
mairie en forme de château
[Musique]
tous ceux qui sont autour de office en
train de jouer sont des Renart la
famille de Django
vous-même vous avez une grand-mère
une fille trois garçons peuvent Diego
l'espagnol à adopté
dans leur vocation
une certaine pour commencer surtout
surtout coco oui parce que Coco lui
c'est il a appris la musique c'est à
dire
il a commencé par le piano et
[Musique]
coucou vous n'avez pas toujours joué
comme ça non il y a combien de temps
vous avez commencé ça fait trois ans
maintenant et maintenant vous composez
je compose aussi oui je fais coconut par
exemple
après j'ai fait chouette
après j'ai fait euro de te revoir
avant
le bassiste à 18 ans
[Musique]
René guitare d'accompagnement 14 ans et
Gilbert le batteur 12 ans
[Musique]
pour eux tous il y a encore une certaine
manière de jouer qui n'appartient aux
enfants
[Musique]
vous avez envie d'apprendre la guitare
[Applaudissements]
il y avait deux guitaristes dans la
famille oui tes parents pensaient qu'ils
pour y en avoir un troisième oui tu as
commencé à prendre la guitare oui j'ai
commencé pendant deux semaines deux
semaines pourquoi tu fais pas ça
[Musique]